Israel out of Sanya has a problem with
an ex-girlfriend now despite the fact
that they do not have a child together
we're never married and I don't remember
her getting in the octagon and throwing
all those punches and kicks she thinks
she should get half of his money because
they're no longer together I'm sure I
should supported him so much but she was
clapping from the sidelines not doing
anything this man worked his balls off
over a decade before he even met you
this would have happened with or without
her and the funniest thing is he dumped
her he then went back in for a title
fight and won the title fight without
her well I never she also said it's not
fun living in his shadow taking second
priority because what he is doing is so
important after a while just makes me
feel small you go after a superstar and
then complain when you're not a power
couple you're not a power couple because
you've been bringing any power to the
couple ironically if she really was
worth half you'd have put a ring on it
guarantee you won't see Israel out of
Sonia asking for half of what she's
worth Will you